what gets you to that point of just like
not being excited and being dissatisfied
with your life is just a slow
accumulation of stress it's not just
like hey you're doing something you
don't like what's happening slowly over
time is we've just been ground down by
modern society really and a lot of
people do drop the hay for 40 50 years
and maybe they maybe it's not a super
stressful job so they don't completely
flame out I think we need to take a
wider lens like what all of these people
are building up this kind of stress and
dissatisfaction and resentment frankly
and to me that is a sort of burnout and
you know maybe it's a different phrase
that's needed that's less descriptive
but I think they need to be looked at
under the same umbrella